-I don't believe
this actually came out today,
but we were expecting that
Robert Mueller was gonna release
the sentencing documents
for Michael Flynn today.
Paul Manafort, we're hearing,
maybe Friday.
These are called
public-facing documents?
-Yeah. It's bringing information
to the public
about why they're doing
what they've been doing.
For instance, for Flynn,
it's about what Flynn
has been providing for them
since he's been cooperating
for a year.
I think they've delayed
his sentencing recommendation
for four different times,
'cause they were
still cooperating.
So this will be whether or not
he thinks Flynn
should face any jail time
and what
he's been doing to help.
-As a betting man,
do you think, in the end,
people will be satisfied
or disappointed?
Let's put it --
When I say "people,"
people who have been looking
to this Mueller investigation
as the moment that it will
all come crashing down.
Do you think they will be
disappointed or satisfied?
-Well, there's certain
left-leaning cable hosts
that I think that
they will be very disappointed,
because it won't be, you know,
literally Donald Trump,
a picture with him
and a smoking gun and, you know,
a tattoo of Vladimir Putin
on his chest.
But I do think it won't be good.
-Yeah.
-I think it'll be ugly.
I don't think it will
necessarily affect him, per se.
And he won't be indicted,
because there's
Justice Department guidelines
that sitting presidents are
seldom, I think, never indicted.
But, look, in the end,
here's the honest answer.
None of us have any idea.
-None of us have any idea.
-Really. I mean, had you ever
heard of George Papadopoulos
before he was --
you know, before that
plea agreement came out?
-I had not, no.
[ Laughter ]
Tell me about this.
Last time you were here,
you were talking about your
"New York Times" best-selling
fiction book, "Hellfire Club."
-Yes.
-You had written
a nonfiction book a ways back
called "The Outpost."
-Yes.
-A wonderful, thrilling book
about a real-life incident
that happened.
And now it's being adapted
into a film?
-That's right.
Rod Lurie, the director,
we just finished shooting
in Bulgaria,
where they had re-created
the entire Army base,
Combat Output Keating.
My family and I,
we went to go visit
and look at this Army base.
There were three actual veterans
who served at COP Keating.
It was attacked.
It was a horrible battle
in 2009.
And they're working on the set.
I hooked them up with Rod.
And they're working on the set
and advising on the movie,
acting in the movie.
And they were there,
and they were kind of, like,
spooked out
but also found it cathartic
that they were on this
recreation of a U.S. base
that had been attacked
and had been destroyed.
-And, obviously,
some lives were lost,
and this is a case
where now people are being --
some of those real-life people
are being portrayed
in this film.
-Yeah. So this is --
That's Rod Lurie, the director.
This is Jacob Scipio.
He's a British actor
who plays Justin Gallegos.
Justin was killed
on October 2, 2009.
And he actually --
He was awarded, posthumously,
a Silver Star,
and the Army just announced
that they're upgrading it to
a Distinguished Service Cross.
So, it's great.
It's a way to honor these men
and their families.
And I hope
it's meaningful for them.
It's been meaningful
to be part of it.
-Another thing we talked about
is your daughter
wrote an op-ed
in "The New York Times."
-NewYorkTimes.com, yes.
-Yes.
-An op-ed about --
-And she is how old now?
-She's 11.
She was 10 when she --
when she and Bari Weiss,
the editor, worked on it.
-Good.
'Cause 11's a little late.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
I'm glad she got it in at 10,
because, by 11,
most people have written their
op-ed in "The New York Times."
-She came up with this
great idea to encourage girls
to raise their hand in class.
She noticed that boys
would raise their hand
even if they had no idea
what the answer was.
Squirrels!
They would -- you know.
But girls didn't do --
Girls were very reticent,
very reluctant.
And so she talked about it
with her Girl Scout troop.
She came up with the idea
for a patch,
a Raise Your Hand patch
to encourage girls
to raise their hand.
And I tweeted
the picture of the patch,
I was so excited,
and Bari Weiss
from "The New York Times"
saw it,
and Alice wrote
an op-ed for "The Times."
-And now it's being adapted --
[ Cheers and applause ]
If you like that, you guys
are gonna be blown away by this.
It's adapted into a book,
"Raise Your Hand."
-"Raise Your Hand."
Yeah.
This is --
It's so great, right?
It comes out in March.
And it's basically
Alice's story.
Marta Kissi
did the illustrations.
They're amazing.
And, yeah, that's Alice.
That's what she looks like.
She's cuter than that.
-That's fantastic.
[ Applause ]
You are also an accomplished --
an accomplished artist.
You do the "State of Cartoonion"
every week.
-Yeah. "State of Cartoonion"
every week, yeah.
-Were you ever in the mix to
maybe do the art for this book?
-No.
Look how good this is.
I mean, this is --
No, no, no.
They asked me.
-I mean, I'm not surprised.
I also think this is better than
yours, but I was wondering...
[ Laughter ]
You knew right away that
you weren't gonna get the gig.
-I didn't want to.
I'm not that good.
This us --
This is amazing stuff.
They did ask me
to do some illustrations
that are in the liner notes,
like, you know,
when you open the book
before you get to the pages.
It's kind of like
the very forgettable pages.
-Yeah. The one you flip through,
because you're like,
"This isn't the book yet."
-This isn't the book.
I'm not in the book.
The liner notes
have some illustrations.
They're not in this copy here.
They have some illustrations
that I did,
but I feel like they did that
to make me feel better.
-Uh-huh, yeah.
Like they wanted
to let you down easy
for the fact that --
-"Well, Alice has
a big book coming out,
and, you know,
but you can do the cartoons.
No, not the ones
that people will look at."
[ Laughter ]
-Are you a little --
Obviously, you know,
now you're both
in the book game.
Are you a little worried
more people are gonna buy
Alice's book?
-I hope more people
buy her book than mine.
Although, we should note,
all of the money,
Alice is donating all of it
to the local chapter
of the Girl Scouts.
-That's fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Because I'm pretty sure
with both of your books,
you famously kept all the money,
right?
-No, no.
For the novel I did,
but I did give a portion
of "The Outpost"
to military charities.
-And let me just say real quick,
because you do so much
with military charities,
and you've helped me
get involved with some of them,
as well.
I remember reaching out to you
to ask what
some of the best are.
-And every year,
when we do our auction,
you donate a visit
to the set here
and a photo-op for our auctions
to raise money
for Homes For Our Troops.
-But you have been
so helpful with me.
Do you feel like, right now,
obviously, we have --
And, again, we're talking about
when you mention John McCain,
you mentioned George H.W. Bush.
You know, obviously,
they served this country.
We have a president
who talks a lot about
how he's the best president
for the military ever.
Real quick, is this country
doing enough for our vets?
-Never. We're never
doing enough for our vets.
I mean, the very fact
that a charity
like Homes For Our Troops
has to exist,
where it builds mortgage-free,
specially-designed homes
for the most
severely wounded veterans
from Afghanistan and Iraq,
just so they can have some
semblance of a normal life,
the very fact that that charity
has to exist
says we're not doing enough
for our veterans.
But what I'm most
concerned about right now is,
I think we're actually now
at a point where
more troops have killed
themselves, post-war,
than died in the first Iraq war
or in the Iraq war,
the most recent Iraq war,
because of the rate
of military suicides.
And so dealing with that
is something that I think
society really
has to grapple with.
-Well,
I certainly agree with you.
And thank you for everything
you do for the vets,
and thank you for being here.
It's always
such a pleasure to see you.
-Happy Hanukkah.
-Happy Hanukkah to you.